happy new year did you have a nice
holiday what did you do we went Chris
and I went up to Washington were both
from there we've got a place up there
and a cabin on the water and my family
came up it was it was very nice like
what do you guys I mean how does it work
is there like a supermarket nearby you
can go cuz whenever someone says you
don't meet me in the cabin yeah well I'm
like no but I want to make sure there's
plenty of food you know yeah and my
husband likes to harvest as he puts it
his his own meat yeah that's the term
what he does on his time is his yeah
wait so knows he hunts my brother and
Chris that hunt and they liked mahant
venison and and well you know deer and
elk and yeah boar yeah like that that's
pretty cool I mean if they I'm totally
fine with hunting if people eat yeah I
think that that's pretty amazing so
that's pretty badass
that Chris goes out and kills his own
food okay yes yeah it's badass and and
like ethically it sounds like the right
thing to do and all that but when you're
the wife I think I'm the only person who
loses weight during the holidays really
well when you're like sawing into like
almost a eat the antler no no but I
would think it would get old just having
that gamey meat all the time you know I
put on a good face yeah you know I think
if he watches his interview he'll know
you despise it
you